I went to my local live blood analysis practitioner,
and he saw signs of oxidation and struggling lip.
He suggested taking diacid,
the kind that will make me blush half-hour before my son-a to give it a boost.
Are there any problems?
Well, you know, I would say there really aren't any problems with flushing.
So understand if you take diacid and a concentration that's causing a flush,
what a flush is is a rapid dilation of your blood vessels,
and you actually get this flushing feeling.
So if anybody has never experienced that taking diacid,
it could actually be scary.
I feel like you could hear like having a stroke or a heart attack
or something like crazy is going on.
It is a really weird feeling going through a flush.
A year ago, there was actually some articles written
that even a person wrote a book about decreasing cholesterol by using diacid and by getting
a flushing diacid, it said the concentration that will cause a flush
and open up your vessels, it helps dump cholesterol and helps with any cholesterol clacking.
I don't know how well that actually worked.
It's kind of fallen off the radar for me as far as patients that we take care of.
But you could do flushing to help with different things
that I don't see any issue with it as far as it goes.
But I will make a comment to what he saw with.
I don't know what he was looking at.
The live blood cell analysis is not legal in most states.
I don't know if it was illegal for any practitioner to do live blood cell analysis
and the practitioners that were jailed because of it.
Now that might even make a person think that it's probably there's more validity to it.
But there is a lot of subjectivity to it.
I've taken some live blood classes by self when I was always intrigued with it.
I thought it was always extremely interesting.
And I actually almost pulled the trigger multiple times getting a microscope.
I don't know if it was myself or the Lord just going to put a stop to it.
Now the issue with it is that there's a lot of subjectivity.
Well, that is the complaint from a standard of care procedure is that it can be difficult to reproduce objective findings.
And so it takes somebody with a lot of experience.
But you could say that with a lot of different techniques, it's difficult to reproduce objective findings.
You have to go to somebody who's really skilled and somebody who trust.
So if this is somebody who's really skilled and somebody who really trusted, they really truly did see oxidation.
And it and signs of lip congestion.
I would say there's any problem with doing the diocese and flush.
But as far as the lip the oxidation goes.
You actually want to produce an oxidative stress if you're trying to kill the cancer.
So, just remember that.
So you made a common oxidative oxidation was visible and dried a lot of the slide organized as a private beverage.
Yeah, he has to do some things to protect himself.
I'm not talking. I'm not talking live blood cell analysis. I'll just say that.
That if he's really good at it. I used to know a guy in Michigan who was really good at it. If I were trust.
And he would do live blood cell analysis and some of the true right conferences.
Here's a great guy.
So.
But it's, it's a river. You're trying to produce an oxidative state to try to kill cancer because you're trying to increase oxidation.
So, I wouldn't do the diocese of flush to decrease that is you might actually be.
You might actually be seeing the evidence of what you are actually trying to do from a nutritional standpoint.
So, but, you know, maybe get a check to get and see what he what he finds.